[Music]
i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight strikes should be the last
resort not the first resort mr speaker
they'll stop customers choosing rail
they'll put jobs at risk they'll cause
misery across the country they'll hit
businesses trying to recover from covid
the british worker needs a pay rise they
need job security decent conditions and
a square deal in general if we can get
that we won't have to have the
disruption in the british economy that
we've got now which may develop across
the summer you know the current cost of
living we know that you need to get paid
but at the same time
don't hold the public transit we do need
to see
in a moderation of wage rises
now that's painful but we need that we
need to see that in order to get through
this problem more quickly
we're not potentially getting a pay rise
you know in the nhs and everything can i
kind of understand it but it's not
the people they need to hit they're not
hitting they are the very same people
the prime minister promised a high-wage
economy too a year ago before presiding
over the biggest fall in living
standards since records began
britain's rail workers say that years of
austerity and covet have left them
impoverished yet all the thanks they get
for keeping the nation moving is a below
inflation pay offer and job insecurity
and they're not alone claim from
teachers and doctors are coming down the
track and picking up momentum
ministers say that the country can't
afford either the money or the
aggravation they accuse the workers of
putting their own interests ahead of the
nation and after all they say who
suffers
other workers who can't get to their
jobs children who can't get to their
exams and patients who can't get to
their treatment
our choice is this week's action a
legitimate cry for help or just
old-fashioned industrial greed who
really does have the national interest
at heart
in the next 30 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight paul novak the deputy
general secretary of the tuc and the
conservative mp claire coutinho who is
also a parliamentary private secretary
to the treasury
um thank you both for being here and
paul there's no um
need to explain why you're not in london
today but thank you for
being it uh there's no real argument
here about the right to strike i don't
think that's our topic for tonight the
question is who's going to benefit from
this particular action so if i want to
start with you paul
um
after two years of covid
with high inflation and a recession on
the horizon
is this really the right
moment
to punish the commuter
well i don't think punishing the
commuter is at the forefront of those
rmt workers uh mine's trevor 40 000 of
them voted to take
industrial action it's not a decision
they would have taken lightly each
single one of those workers is going to
lose
pay but i think they've done it because
they feel that they have no alternative
they're worried about compulsory
redundancies
they're worried about uh yet another
real terms uh pay cut and so that they
you know after trying i have to say
through many many months of negotiations
and trying to move both the transport
employers
and the government they they felt that
they've had no alternative at all and
now i was speaking to some of those
pickets uh today in liverpool
my hometown these are people who care
deeply about the railways and the people
that they said
none of them want to be standing outside
stations they want to be in station
serving the traveling public but they
felt that they had no alternative and i
would hope that people would respect
that decision respect how difficult a
decision it was
and we're absolutely clear that the tuc
stands four square
behind the rmt
in its action and its proposed actions
because uh mr lynch the
leader of the rmt says this could go on
for months
well i'm pretty sure that mick lynch and
his members don't want to go on for for
months but what they absolutely want to
see is a negotiated uh fair settlement
but absolutely those rnt workers have my
support and the support of the tc and
indeed any
worker that
difficult decision to take industrial
action uh would have our support you
know we talked a lot in the introduction
there about the cost of living crisis
i'd argue our cost of living crisis in
the uk is actually a wages crisis if
wages in this country have risen at the
same rate they have on average across
the oecd over the last decade the
average british worker would be 4 000
a year better off last year the prime
minister told us that he wanted to
create a high-wage economy now he's
telling us we need to exercise pay
restraints and those two things don't
add up trevor and you know i think we
need to debate in this country about how
are we going to get wages rising again
all right we'll come back to some of
that detail clear continue you belong to
a party
which is reluctant for the state to step
into people's day-to-day lives i i know
you yourself support trade unionism
why are you getting involved in an
industrial dispute at all why are you
here well so i represent a massive
commuter area and what these strikes
mean is that for my workers their best
case scenario is that they work from
home the worst case scenarios they can't
get to work and they won't get paid so i
think these strikes are very very
difficult for workers across the country
i think they're also very damaging to an
economy which is in a fragile recovery
which we spent 400 billion pounds on
during the pandemic trying to preserve
and also i don't think they're good for
the real workers themselves if you look
at what's happened in the railway
industry revenues are down i think
something like 40 in some cases
passengers have not returned back to the
railways in the way that they were using
them pre-covered and what they need to
do to ensure i think a sustainable
future is to attract passengers back not
push them away
and also make sure that they're making
those modernising changes so you can
have a really efficient productive
service that is good for the rail
workers and it's good for passengers
well
i hear the case and that's the case made
by government ministers but just um
dealing with
your position as a member of parliament
representing your constituents i mean to
some extent you are representing an
interest legitimate but just as
sectional as the interest
represented by the rmt
you are here and making the case for a
group of people who don't want their
lives disrupted uh uh paul noeck and the
rmt represent a group of people who feel
that their lives have been impoverished
so it's a this is a battle between
sectional interest rather than one for
the interest of the country as a whole
isn't it well i would actually slightly
disagree with that because one of the
things that i think the rail industry is
not doing is actually looking after the
long term interest of the real workers
themselves and that's something which is
not i'm just not saying it's just me you
had people like a former labor cabinet
minister david blunkett this morning who
was saying the same thing because if you
want those workers to have long-term pay
rises which i think we can all agree
that we do we do want those things and
it has to be a productive efficient
service and you've got to get those
passenger volumes up
all right let's um let's get into the uh
the case that each of you essentially
represents and starting with you paul um
would you accept that
it won't be the billionaires who pay
uh if the the increase that's being
asked for seven percent or they're about
uh is delivered it won't really be
billionaires though that's the popular
thing to say
but ordinary commuters because they'll
have to pay increased fares
and ordinary families in the shape of
increased taxes to support the
infrastructure
i don't think you can make that direct
connection uh trevor i mean that ignores
the fact for example that the train
operating companies made 500 million
pounds in profits during the uh pandemic
it ignores the fact that hundreds of
millions of pounds were paid out to
outsourcing firms to carry out
maintenance worker on our railways
during
the pandemic now just going back to what
claire said there everybody wants to see
a successful thriving modern efficient
railway in this country and i i'll let
you in on a secret during the pandemic
myself mick lynch other rail union
leaders met on quite a regular basis
actually with the then conservative uh
rail minister to talk about not only how
we dealt with uh the pressures of the
pandemic but we also talked about what
was going to happen post pandemic and
how we could get people back
onto trains and run an effective service
i have to say all of that came to a
crashing halt in october last year when
the chancellor made his um
spending review and now
slashing funding to our rail services
the shutters then came down we haven't
met minister since march of this year so
there is scope to have a sensible
discussion about how we run a modern uh
railway i would argue actually there's
there's no need for hundreds of millions
of pounds to be lost in the system uh to
the private train operating companies
that's a debater to be had but actually
you know
that discussion needs to involve and
engage the workforce not be imposed upon
them and i've been in lots and lots of
private sector organizations where you
know everywhere from car plants
uh uh to uh
companies in the insurance and banking
sector and if you want to manage big
transition what you do is try and bring
people with you and you do things like
saying right what we're going to do is
have no compulsory redundancies that's
been completely the opposite approach
taken by i'm afraid the government
and by my extension the train operating
companies and network rail all right let
me let me put the point about um the
government meetings to claire coutinho
because i think mr shap said that the
government had met
that there had been dozens of meetings i
think he said 60 or there about um
is it a failure
not to
have got this sorted out before now
well i mean i would just say two things
like the chief executive of network rail
and paul was talking about profits there
that is a public organization
said that the unions had used strikes as
a first resort not as a last resort and
that they had walked out because they
didn't want to update their working
practices so i'm not sure what the
government can do when the union is not
putting forward these modernization
measures that we want and if you look
back historically so you can look back
at labour years i think into tony blair
and gordon brown there was strikes with
unis at that point and the unions always
say can the minister come to those
meetings and they didn't in those cases
because actually what you need is very
detailed discussions between the
employer and the unions about what kind
of updates are necessary and actually
network braille said they thought it'd
be very unhelpful to have a meeting with
grant chaps because that is not the
technical discussion which needs to take
place that they want to see
paul now i just want to be clear about
something um
on the one hand uh i think that the
unions were saying last week that the
really big problem here was that the
government was interfering with
negotiations uh but this week they seem
to be saying that actually the
government should be right at the center
of negotiations what is a tuc view about
this should mr schatz be in it or he
should be out of it
well clearly grant shaps holds the key
to unlock this dispute because actually
it is the department for transport
that's set to the financial envelope
within which both uh network rail which
is in public uh hands and the private
train operating companies operate and
there's two interesting things there uh
trevor in the terms of the contracts
that the train operating companies have
with the dft it's very clear that the
secretary of state has the power to
direct those companies in regard to
issues around employment relations the
other thing is that actually he also has
the ability to indemnify those companies
if they have losses because of
industrial action so this is so you've
got an employer that is effectively not
incentivized to reach a resolution
because the department of transport is
effectively writing blank checks behind
the scene so i don't think that grand
chaps can wash his hands of
responsibility i would want him
envelope that allows the train operating
companies network rail to reach a fair
resolution and that's in everybody's
interest let me put that to clear that
mr shaps
might want to do the pontius pilot thing
and wash his hands but he's actually got
his fingers in the pie already so i
think to be honest this is a bit of a
ruse because the request for the meeting
came on the very date that we had this
debate in parliament it wasn't there
before in the public domain and actually
what this is trying to divert attention
from is that the union has broken down
talks with their employer about updating
modern working practices and that's not
me government saying that that as i said
is industry that is the chief executive
of network rail who is saying actually
the problem is they're not putting
forward credible changes which means
that we can get these productivity
changes that we need to make the
railways work well
all right let's um let's move on let's
talk a bit about your
uh as it were defensive government
claire the truth is government could
afford this uh what we're being told by
the obr i think is that the treasury
will expect a 30 billion pound
surplus in the public finances that is
30 billion more uh receipts in taxes
than uh spent and spend plans to spend
why not spend it supporting people's
living standards and getting that money
into the economy well firstly i would
say we have actually spent a lot of
money and tried to support people's
living standards we've spent 37 billion
pounds on doing just that and actually
one of the things that i haven't heard
much from the unions is the fact that a
lot of our support will go against the
lowest paid workers that's where the
majority of the money goes so if you're
on i don't know something like 20 000
pounds and you're in the rail industry
and you're on a means-tested benefit not
unlikely one in three families in this
country are then you'll be getting 1200
pounds of support for cost of living
this year you'll also be getting the
changes from the universal credit tapery
which can be as much as a thousand
pounds if you're full time on the living
wage you also may be getting help from
the national insurance thresholds so you
might actually be getting about nine
percent of support from those things so
why should the taxpayer pay again for
another nine percent for those workers
and isn't it right that we're trying to
target the most money at the people who
are the lowest paid
well as i said before trevor i think
that whatever support that the
government has made available to the
lowest paid and let's remember that
support came
just a few months after the chancellor
ended that uplifting universal credit
just uh weeks after the chance to put up
taxes on working people in terms of a
national insurance height but what it
doesn't do is address the central issue
which is that wages are not growing in
this country and it doesn't matter
whether you work in the public or
private sector we have got a wages
crisis one in five people earn less than
the real living wage three quarters of
the kids who live in poverty in this
country have at least one parent who
goes out to work think about that a
parent who goes out to work and their
family is still on the breadline so i
think what what the government needs to
be doing is working with employers in
unions to think about how do we boost
pay now the government has a direct role
in the public sector as an employer
rishi soon act told us last year that he
was going to end the public sector pay
freeze and then told workers this year
to expect uh paid restraint but in the
private sector there's things that
government could be doing as as well it
could boost the minimum wage it could
encourage employers to to negotiate with
unions there are some big issues in our
economy and the government is failing on
all of them
we're going to have the the highest
minimum wage i think in the whole of
europe we are boosting that's exactly
what we did in autumn last year when we
were looking at the cost of living
crisis in advance we did the universal
credit taper rate as i said that means a
lot to people who are working in the
lowest paid jobs so i don't think it's
right at all to say that government
isn't doing anything for the lowest paid
i think that is completely false i think
the question that you need to ask
yourself is why taxpayers who are not
earning as much as some of the workers
in the rail industry should be
subsidized subsidizing a pay increase
for them that they themselves are not
going to get yeah i'm not interested in
driving wedges between groups of working
people i'd ask the question in the rail
industry why are we paying out hundreds
of millions of pounds in profits to
private train operating companies why
not put that money in the pockets of our
press rail work because i i went to look
at the office of rail and road on that
and what they said is that last year six
out of the eight franchising companies
paid 38 million pounds in dividends
which was a 200 million pound decrease
on the year before and about 0.3 of
operating income so i know that the
unions want to paint this all as rampant
profiteering but isn't it true that
actually had the 20 billion pounds of
income they got last year 16 billion
pounds came from the taxpayer so what
you're talking about is money that's
going to come from the taxpayer to fund
these
from these wage increases
rail services
around the world are funded by taxpayers
because it's part of having a coherent
public transport system we are almost
unique certainly in europe though in
having a rail system where hundreds of
millions of pounds of that subsidy
effectively ends up in the pockets of
private companies
claire before we uh try to see if we can
find any common ground here let me ask
you one thing um
ministers have been boasting recently
about the fact that the nation's got
more jobs available pretty much than
there are people to fill them um isn't
one consequence of this
jobs bonanza to use
a term of art that labor now has more
leverage i mean that's the economics of
it so why are you
wanted to interfere with the market
surely what mr lynch and his colleagues
are doing are simply following the logic
of the market they've suddenly got this
capacity because we're in a tight labor
market
where they can use their muscle to
improve the position for their members
why does a conservative government want
to introdu into uh fear with the
workings of the market so i don't think
anyone's view of the market is that you
know wages should follow profit so i
don't think hurting the economy
therefore reducing the amount of profit
that people are creating is the best way
to increase wages across the economy
which is exactly what the the rail
unions are doing here um but i think
generally it's good i actually am very
supportive of unions i think it's good
that they have a collective voice for
workers it's good that they increase
their bargaining power i think it's
actually miraculous that we have the
strength in the job market that we're
seeing we were very worried about 20
unemployment and actually i know some of
the unions worked very closely um with
the government on things like the
furlough scheme which have done so well
to preserve jobs i just don't see why
you would now hurt the economy and say
that is how we're going to have
sustainable wage increases going forward
all right all right let's um we've heard
from both of you now and uh what you
think let's get to the hard part and see
if we can find any common ground or at
least some common understanding
um
there was a time when
uh
trade union leaders
employers and politicians would sit down
together to try to solve a problem like
that uh people rather sneeringly
describe this as beer and sandwiches um
and it sort of went out of fashion um
paul novak would the uh
would the thc like to go back to the
days of
len murray vic feather george woodcock
i'm revealing my age when i can remember
because i can remember the names of all
of these tuc general secretaries who
were big figures who would be in and out
of number 10. is that where you guys
want to get back to
well i don't think we want to go exactly
back to the 1950s 60s and 70s and we do
have female trade union leaders uh now
as well including francis o'grady
obviously at the
at the at the tc
you know you're absolutely right though
trevor there was a period after the war
in fact it was it was born out of the
contribution that unions made during the
second world war that was a post-war
consensus that unions had an important
role to play that disappeared at the end
of the 70s i think that there is
absolutely much more uh scope for unions
employers and government to be working
together and claire mentioned it you
know the the fellow scheme was a really
good example of that actually the cbi
and the t you see working with the
chancellor to put in place a scheme they
protected the livelihoods of millions of
people i worked very closely with
employers in the department of business
to develop safe working guidance that
kept people safe during the
pandemic but it seems like the
government feels that trade unions are
only good for a crisis and and
it's really regrettable i think that the
prime minister has gone back to
what feels like i have to say union
bashing rather than accepting that
unions have a legitimate role to play
that we're trying to represent
working people as effectively as we can
and i think that there is scope to work
together on some of these big issues
that the uk labour market and indeed the
economy face
correct so i mean i i don't think that
completely represents i have a lot of
sympathy for paul's point because it's
true the unions did work very closely
with us in government and have done
great work over the years for workers
rights i think they're generally a force
for good i think what we're dealing with
here is a very militant branch of a
union which has used a strike as a first
resort as opposed to sitting around the
negotiating table and is now politicking
and trying to cause trouble because
frankly i just don't think it likes
having a tory government um and what
would be actually much better if is if
the union sat down with the employers as
the employers are asking and worked out
how they can make the railways fit for
passengers post pandemics so it suits
their suits their needs and one of those
things is you know weekend working so i
actually have a rail franchising line
gtr which has adopted a lot of these
modern working practices and actually it
decided not to strike and i'm very
commended very much those workers for
doing so so these things are possible
but i do think the unions need to do
more negotiation and less political but
it won't necessarily be the case for all
of the other strikes that are coming
down the track teachers doctors are not
quite going to be as amenable as you'd
like them to be well i mean i think
those two things that i would say is i
completely sympathize with people saying
look at the look at inflation we need to
have a pay rise we have an independent
pay review body those are experts who
look exactly at what's going on and they
put forward recommendations and then
government has to look at that and of
course government has to have some
consideration of affordability because
if they're spending all of their money
on pay rises and they don't have the
money to do that they might have to take
away from services so that's something
that they need to balance but everyone
has sympathy with people saying look
cost of living is really hard the thing
that i would just point to is for the
people who are facing the sharpest end
of the wedge on cost of living like i'm
laid out before there is actually a lot
of support and that's true for teachers
that's true for people who work in the
the health sector as well
is it a case paul for um the cec to
remind
some of its members and
i i know there's a
some rather unfair comparisons being
made about um rail workers salaries
there are very poorly paid
members of the rmt as well as some
rather well paid members of the rmt but
is there a case perhaps for
reminding those who have industrial
muscle and who can
uh essentially use that to
bid up the price of their own labor that
that might be at the cost of fellow
workers
no well let's first of all nail the myth
uh trevor that the rail workers are
incredibly well paid in fact the median
wage on the on the railways is almost
exactly the same as the median wage
across the country as a whole in many
ways the rmt
are the country's middle workers that
they are the middle workers and i i'd
ask i'd ask clarity to go down to one of
those picket lines and talk to the staff
there because these are not people who
are militants or in any way politically
motivated
remember mick lynch doesn't get to vote
on whether or not rmt members take
industrial action i don't get to vote
the people who get to vote are the rail
workers themselves and there was 40 000
of them voted to take industrial action
now the government changed the law a few
years back to make it difficult for
people to take industrial action you now
have to have a majority not just of
those who vote but who are eligible to
vote that's a bar that few mps would
pass actually in terms of representation
it's a bar we don't put any any other
type of um democratic process in this
country and they they voted in
accordance with the law and they voted
because they think it's the right thing
to do when they want their employers and
the government to listen so i'd go and
talk to people and listen to their
stories because actually these are
people who just want a fair deal they
really do want a fair deal
i have talked to some real worker
constituents about this issue but isn't
it true that the ballot was
organized before pay was properly
discussed and isn't it true that what
the unions were saying to people is
you're not going to get a pay rise this
year which isn't the case actually i
think everyone is widely acknowledged
repeatedly that there will be a pay rise
but they also need to see some of these
modernizing changes which like i said i
think is a good thing for rail workers
to be in better productive jobs claire
before we move before i want to ask each
of you a question before we end but
would would it help
if the government were to make clear
that it's going to resist the calls from
some members of your party
to essentially impose more restrictive
uh legislation on trade union action
trade union right that actually if you
like as a gesture of goodwill that the
government would say that it might think
about restoring some of the rights and
powers that trade unions used to have to
organize
so i think what the government is trying
to look to do is to work out in the face
of very very militant union action how
it can keep the economy going so it's
talked about agency workers i know paul
will have his views on that it's talked
about having a minimum level of service
so that you can keep the economy going
and i completely i mean i think paul
would probably have sympathy with us as
well understand why government is saying
this is not the time to have a uh you
know a
bang to the economy actually what we
need to do is make sure that people can
recover and also we want people to go
back and use the trains we spent 16
billion pounds to keep the railways
going because we wanted people to go
back and use the trains after the
pandemic all right i'm going to ask each
of you for 30 seconds to tell me if
you've heard anything from
this conversation that has made you
think again about where you started paul
well i i i i respect the the fact that
claire recognizes that there's a
legitimate role for trade unions i'm
just afraid that the government is
intent on on pulling out the old
playbook around union bastion and i
don't think that they appreciate that
what unions are trying to do is to
represent working people their families
as effectively as they can we need to
work together to boost wages in this
country to get the economy growing again
attacking trade unions the very
organizations that stand up for working
people won't help that one iota and you
know the biggest risk to our economy is
working people not having money in their
pockets not spending it in local
economies so there's a responsibility on
government to talk sensibly to unions to
talk sensibly to workers and to
employers about how we're going to boost
wages in this country
rather than raising red flags around
summers of discontent and all the rest
of it so i appreciate paul is doing his
job and representing his members and i
do you know like i said i have a lot of
respect for for him and what he's doing
but i don't think the way to put money
in people's pockets is to stop them
getting to work
that's my bottom line
all right well look one thing that
strikes me and this hasn't come up in
our conversation at all but uh i i can't
help but say week after week i come i
come in here we have these conversations
and i think how lucky a politician is
boris johnson that something always
comes along to take the limelight off
his current difficulties and that
happened this week secondly
one thing that's emerged out of this
conversation which i think is very
interesting is that there might be a
place once again for beer and sandwiches
partly to without drawing government
into two places it shouldn't be
to take the heat out of some of these
issues and maybe perhaps restore a
little bit of power to the trade union
congress as opposed to some of its
more independent let's call it uh
members and maybe claire
that might be a way in which uh this
government can distinguish itself from
uh some of its sort of ideological
outliers uh to extend the hand of
friendship to a trade union anyway you
know
sky's happy to provide um some beer and
some sandwiches if everybody wants to
get to get get in a room
thank you very much both of you for you
see are one and the same trevor i assure
you thank you very much for being with
us um stay with us we will have all
today's news coming up after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
hello there good evening to you you're
watching sky news our top stories
tonight millions of commuters have been
affected by rail strikes which have seen
four fifths of the uk's train services
cancelled
well the rmt said the turnout on picket
lines exceeded expectations but the
government questioned the success of the
rail strikers many people opted to work
from home to avoid the disruption
and u.s officials say police in texas
could have stopped an hour-long school
shooting in which 21 people died within
the first three minutes
let's go straight to washington for more
on this then and speak to our u.s
correspondent mark stone and mark this